ich sehe eigentlich immer passend aus zu
meinen Adventskalendern die ich
vorstelle heute nicht letztes Jahr als
ich den Paul Valentine Adventskalender
ausgepackt habe sah ich ein bisschen
mehr Pol Valentine mäßig aus heute habe
ich mein Nina chuber fangir T-Shirt an
Support geht raus seit der ersten Stunde
das hält uns aber nicht davon ab diesen
wunderbaren Kalender auszupacken dieses
Video ist definitiv nicht gesponsert und
jetzt alle dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsert ich habe mir diesen Kalender
selbst gekauft weil ich letztes Jahr so
begeistert davon war ich trag den
Schmuck von Paul Valentine also die
Ohrringe sehr gerne ich habe absolut
keine allergische Reaktion darauf
bekommen das ganze Jahr über meistens
habe ich von Ohring so ein rotes
glühendes Ohr ich krieg sogar dann so
ein bisschen so hier roten Ausschlag
sogar manchmal ein paar Pickelchen und
bei dem Paul Valentine Schmuck war es
nicht der Fall und wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere dann hat mir dieser Kalender
letztes Jahr sehr gut gefallen hier ist
aber nicht nur Schmuck drin ich würde
mir natürlich wünschen dass nur Schmuck
drin ist aber ich glaube das würde den
preislichen Rahmen sprengen Dios Mios
199,90 € kostet dieser Adventskalender
170 € wir hoffen dass er sich gohnt ich
habe die silberne Variante mir dieses
Mal ausgesucht crazy ich bin eigentlich
ein goldschmucktyp glaube ich zumindest
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß nicht wie man
so was rausfindet oh machen wir jetzt
ein bisschen farblehere ich habe mal
gehört wenn die Adern blau Aussehen bist
so ein kalter Typ wenn sie grün Aussehen
bist du ein warmer Typ oder du bist ein
neutraler Typ ich dachte mal ich bin
warmer Typ aber meine Adern sind
ziemlich violettblau aber ich werde so
schnell braun ich weiß es nicht oh
mensch Leute der ist sogar noch zur
Verfügung den gibt's sogar noch hat der
nicht letztes Mal so krank schnell
ausverkauft der soll einen warenwerert
von
811 € und 20 Cent
haben da sind fast 1000 € Warenwert
drin
to da freuen wir uns doch das müssen wir
auf jeden Fall nachrechnen Tag nicht
entfernen dieser tikel kann ich z Z
gegeben werden sobald ich das Tag
entferne okay also erster Eindruck schon
mal toll tolle Farben tolle Schleife auf
der Schleife steht sogar Paul Valentine
in Gold geschrieben und wir öffnen ach
toll ist schön nur sehr wackelig und
diese Tür
nervt das wie letztes ich habe die
Flashbacks letztes Jahr ist auch schon
so also der reißt hier Seite schon
wieder ein bisschen auf das ist geklebt
und das geht immer so auf
und egal ich beschw mich nicht 811 €
let's go Türchen Nummer
1 das hätte jetzt wirklich nicht so eine
große Schachtel sein müssen aber gut wir
fangen direkt mit Schmuck
an oh ich habe Bock ich habe Bock auf
Silberschmuck ich weiß nicht
warum meine es ist das erste Türchen und
was andere Hersteller nicht checken das
erste Türchen muss knallen guckt euch
mal diesen glänzenden Stein an bei
Swarowski würde der jetzt 3000 €
kostenarowski hat auch
Metallketten und nicht Silber oh no es
ist auch Metall oder ist es nee hier ist
keine Zahl drauf müssen wir gleich mal
kurz nach gucken weil die der
Goldschmuck war vergoldet 14 Karat
vergoldet bei dem Silberschmuck bin ich
mir jetzt nicht so sicher okay was sagen
wir cute ich will mich nur nicht ärgern
dass ich den nicht in Gold ne nee das
sieht super aus in Silber die
Schmuckstücke sind aus Edelstahl bei der
Gold und rosé goldoldvion mit einer 14
Karat Gold und 14 Karat roséegold
Plattierung alle enthaltenen Produkte
sind robust und langlebig okay das ist
Edelstahl also kein Silber es hat nur
die Farbe silber hm muss das mal gucken
wie ich es dann vertragen werde bei Gold
habe ich gut vertragen komisch dass sie
aber dann gleich viel kostet ne aus
Edelstahl und wenn man es dann vergoldet
nehmen Sie kein extra Preis
65,90 € kostet das Teil kurzer
Disclaimer wenn ich Preise raussuche und
dann finde ich z.B manch mal nicht die
genaue Kette dann schreibe ich ein
ähnlichen Preis auf also meine Rechnung
kann immer nicht 100% stimmen nur damit
wir so ein rchtwert haben Nummer 2 eine
ritualserze sweet Jasmine riecht sehr
gut h sie da einfach nur so drin war ne
ist halt eine probegröße ja das ist doch
wie ein Teelicht oder wie zwei ungefähr
6 € kla kumna ist wieder unterwegs
sensationell ich habe Flashbacks die
haben sie es da nicht hinkriegen
können ich frage mich was S für ein
Verpacker haben Paul Valentine ist
wirklich der einzige Adventskalender bei
dem das so schlimm ist ich glaube weil
alle Pakete einfach viel zu leicht sind
kein Gewicht hier herrscht was soll man
denn tun ich sag mal so wir lassen das
jetzt Nummer 3 sag mal ist das hier ein
Rituals Adventskalender zum zweiten Mal
R
schergel 2,50 2,50
also da bin ich gespannt wie wir zu 800
kommen Nummer vi auch wenn ich nicht
zugeben mag ich finde die Produkte von
barbo echt irgendwie cool also wenn ich
mir diese Ampullen ins Gesicht Schmiere
habe ich das Gefühl für ein Tag wirkt
meine Haut dann ein bisschen feuchter
straffer und so weiter und hier haben
wir eine hyaluroncreme 21 € 17 die packe
ich aber euch natürlich in die
verlosungsbox wie auch fast alle
Produkte aus diesem Adventskalender wenn
ihr mir jetzt auf Instagram folgt dann
bekommt ihr mit ab wann die
adventskalenderverlosungen losgehen und
vielleicht könnt ihr einen
selbstgepackten Adventskalender von mir
gewinnen dieser schachtelhaufen hier
Nummer 5 man erwartet es einfach nur
wann kommt das nächste Schmuckstück ich
hätte jetzt gedacht bei Türchen Nummer
6 ich wollte gerade schon sagen der
pasende Armreif für meine Kette Armreif
das klingt auch so ich habe zu ein
dünnes Handgelenk kan man das ein
bisschen kürzen ne das ist das
kürzeste das gefällt mir tatsächlich
nicht so weil es halt so groß ist und
man es nicht noch kürzer machen kann m
na obwohl ich bin ein nicht gewohnt am
Handgelenk irgendwie Schmuck zu tragen
ja nee und es ist mir halt bisschen zu
groß dann muss ich das Verschenken 55,90
€ also sind wir bei dem Set schon über
€ soll aber eine hochwertige Qualität
haben was mir bei den Oring echt
aufgefallen ist also ich habe die jetzt
ein Jahr lang sehr sehr oft getragen
Nikolaus es ist Nikolaus und wir gehen
zu unserem Adventskalender wir freuen
uns extrem Bor ja gut das Paket war auch
sehr schwer highölcleenser also ehrlich
gesagt gut vielleicht ist es manchen
einfach nicht so wichtig aber ich hätte
jetzt gedacht dass das schöne Nikolaus
aber vielleicht ist NCO ist Valentine
die sind sehr international mittlerweile
ne wir vergessen mal einfach dass heute
Nikolaus ist oh ist eine Kombi ah es ist
eine Kombi aus Cleanser und boosting
hydration aber beide Produkte sehen mir
nach Probe Größen aus ja guck mal das ja
definitiv wow okay 200 ml kosten
27,99 € haben wir schon mal 7 € für die
cleansergröße und
7,47 ich kann euch zwar nicht zur
Wirkung sagen aber die Verpackung sieht
toll aus hier ist so Holo drauf auf
diesem Kanal gibt's nur Qualität dafür
stehe ich mit meinem Namen Nummer s vor
Nikolaus und nach Nikolaus Schmuck an
Nikolaus nicht Ohringe Ohringe bitte
Ohringe Ohringe ich will Ohringe
uh guck mal solche hatte ich ja noch
nicht schick die schreien doch Party ich
finde das Design sehr schön es ist
zeitlos ihr könnt ihr mal bitte sagen ob
mir Silberschmuck steht oh wenn jetzt
meine Ohren rot werden ne dann weine ich
dass ich nicht den goldenen geholt habe
hol eigentlich noch irgendwer Ros
goldold ich hab das Gefühl rosegold oh
also klar jetzt nicht zu diesem Outfit
und so ne aber guckt mal
aber ich meine selbst bei briot Bri
gibt's doch Sterling Silber und da ist
es nicht mal so teuer also dass es
irgendwie mit Silber überzogen ist oder
so ich verstehe nicht warum hier nicht
mal echtes Silber überzogen wurde also
ich meine optisch sind die wirklich
wirklich toll aber es passt halt auch
gar nicht zusammen ne kostet das jetzt
nur 30 € und das andere so viel 32 € A
schon wieder Schmuck die haben bisschen
die Erwartungshaltung wieder
runtergeschraubt und jetzt schrauben Sie
die wieder ganz schnell nach oben jetzt
gibt ganz viel Schmuck hintereinander uh
sind da sind wow hier drauf sind die
Sternzeichen tolles Motiv und ist hier
ein bisschen länger dann kann ich alle
gleichze oh das gefällt mir schon sehr
gut Tata passt das zusammen ich glaube
nicht ich glaube hier passt nichts
zusammen okay sternzeichenkette 55,90 €
also wir kommen auf jeden Fall über 170
€ das ist schon mal sicher die finde ich
richtig cool die werde ich gerne tragen
das weiß ich jetzt schon ja jetzt kommt
erst mein lieblingstürchen ist das neun
oder ist das eine se mein
lieblingstürchen Türchen Nummer
ne
jawollo neun ist und bleibt mein
lieblingstürchen der real Magnet hier
ist ein Magnet drauf ich habe nur
gesehen dass das ein Produkt von Benefit
ist und das reicht mir meistens dass ich
mich freue eine
Mascara ich habe zwar gesagt ich habe
schon genug Mascara
aber leider nur eine probegröße ich
glaub die meisten Sachen die von Benefit
bei mirem hatte war immer probegrößen
weil ich mir nie was selbst gekauft habe
ich hatte eigentlich gedacht dass es das
Augenbrauen Zeug was ich liebe aber ist
Mascara die originale Größe kostet 30 €
ungefähr die Hälfte also 15 € könnt ihr
es glauben aber es ist von Benefit und
deswegen mag ich kleines Ratespiel was
kommt nach der neu genau die Nummer 10
und es ist wieder Schmuck kommt mir vor
als ob dieses Jahr mehr Schmuck drin ist
als letztes Jahr Bo die finde ich doch
ich bin froh ich habe halt überhaupt
kein Silberschmuck und solche kolen die
kann man immer gut gebrauchen wenn man
mal so ein Outfit hat wo einfach Silber
viel besser passt komm wir setzen sie
daneben ja das
sieht interessant aus na gut kommen die
alten ABS anziehen und ausziehen fühlt
sich bei den Ohrringen bisschen
schwierig an das ist meckern auf hohem
Niveau ich weiß aber die Haptik fühlt
sich irgendwie komisch an das ist so
kratzig und so und so fest
und
WoW 57,90 € Nummer 11 noch mal Schmuck
Paul Valentine ihr am Anfang so viele
andere Produkte reingemacht ne dass man
denkt so oh da ist nicht so viel von
denen drin jetzt kommen sie ein Ring oh
mein Gott yes ich habe mich noch gefragt
ob die es nicht irgendwie hin also dass
sie es nicht machen können dass man ein
Ring bekommt den halt alle irgendwie
tragen können und ja dieser Ring lässt
sich halt in der Breite so verstellen
dass den so jeder tragen kann da wo mein
Verlobungsring ist kann ich den ja nicht
tragen ne undter neben sie das auch D
sch muss ich den an anderen Hand tragen
ich bin an zwei verschiedene Männer
verlobt tolles Design kann man echt
nicht meckern also den Ring der hier ist
ein ganz zarter da ist nichts dran Ring
na machen wir 27,90 € 12 Halbzeit ich
flipp doch aus GI die sind frech zwei
Rituals Produkte hintereinander und
jetzt kommen sie mit dem ganzen Schmuck
um die Ecke wow toll kann ich auch
eigentlich mal was anderes sagen außer
toll ich mag das Design total gerne weil
das einfach aussieht wie so ganz viele
Augen oder wie so eine Fahrradkette mega
ich hänge hier auch einfach 3 kg Schmuck
dran kein Problem mit diesem Kalender
werdet ihr selber zum Weihnachtsbaum
vielleicht trennen wir uns jetzt mal von
der viel besser wow tolles Design ja
silberne Kette mit Augen Mann ich Brau
doch jetzt einfach nur diese Kette mit
den Augen bra 300 Mal die gleiche das
habt ihr nicht ne hier wir nehmen die
77,90 € ich ja Nummer 13
excuse
mE barbor ist das ein Kalender mit
barbor Rituals und Dings ne also der
absolute win ist es ja wenn man von
beiden Fan ist wenn man barbor Fan ist
und Schmuck dann hat man halt einfach
beides 7 ml Originalgröße für 20,90 € 14
jetzt kommen sie wieder die Partner
relaxing Body Scrub ich glaube ich habe
sogar das bodyscrub vom letzten Jahr ich
habe das nicht so wirklich benutzt wenn
ich meine Haut pielen möchte dann mache
ich das jetzt mittlerweile mit einem
Waschlappen ich habe mehrere Waschlappen
und nach jedem
Benutzen schmeiße ich in die Wäsche und
dann ma ich da ein bisschen Duschgel
drauf ich habe so ein tiktok gesehen und
das hat mein Leben verändert dass sie
sich immer mit dem Waschlappen so
abwäschen na ja und vorher habe ich halt
so ein Massagehandschuh benutzt aber der
soll anscheinend ein bisschen also eine
Bakterienschleuder sein deswegen ich mag
solche Peelings und ich finde es auch
cool wenn man mal so ein Bad nimmt und
sich irgendwie was besonderes so gönnen
möchte aber man macht's halt dann nicht
wirklich manche Produkte sind finde ich
schöner im Gedanken so die Vorstellung
davon dieses Produkt zu benutzen ist
schöner und realistischer als dass man
es am Ende wirklich benutzt hä und eine
Sache das muss ich auch sagen aber ich
weiß nicht woher das kommt
wahrscheinlich aus der Kindheit und
Jugend da hatte ich halt nicht so viel
Möglichkeiten und da war ich immer
sparsam mit allem was ich hatte und
diese Sparsamkeit habe ich jetzt aber
auch immer noch auf alle Produkte die
ich habe ich mir denke ich habe ja
dieses Produkt um es zu benutzen wess
hör auf es zu sparen weil irgendwann
wird's schlecht nach 12 Monaten und dann
ja toll dann hast du dir das gespart D
hast du dir literally das Produkt
gespart good J ja bodyrub kriegt ihr 300
g Kosten bei Douglas 13,49 € ja ist
ungefähr die Hälfte ma wir 7,50 € das
bekommt ihr damit es in eurem Bad
rumsteht und ihr es euch sparen könnt 15
ich bin begeistert Schmuck wird gegönnt
Ohring ja toll jetzt habe ich aber nee
komm also die sind toll die sind
wirklich hübsch aber die sehen den so
ähnlich die haben fast die gleiche Größe
und halt eigentlich fast das gleiche
Design interesting choice Paul Valentine
wir rechnen mal 2790 meine Ohrringe die
ich vom letzten Jahr habe die fühlen
sich irgendwie viel hochwertiger an
natürlich ist das jetzt ein Hohlraum das
ja auch gut damit sie leichter sind am
Ohr ich weiß aber nicht warum das sieht
irgendwie jetzt ist ja s krasser aus wie
ist das bei dem anderen Schmuck ja gut
nee bei dem anderen schmuck sieht sehr
hochwertig aus i don't know ich bin
bisschen her gerissen 16 16 ist wieder
ein sehr leichtes Paket
okay also Paul Valentine nette Idee ne
wirklich nette Idee aber dieses Ding
fühlt sich so trashig an ne lass mal ist
ist aus Seide oder sowas ne sicher nicht
das fühlt sich so plastikmäßig an wir
rechnen dafür mal erstmal keinen Preis
17 barbor Spa handcam ich habe so viel
Handcreme die geh an euch F von F Stern
hat
sie 64 Nummer 18 Schmuck Schmuck Schmuck
Schmuck Schmuck Schmuck Schmuck
natürlich klar das passende augenarm
reif ich hö auf Armreifen zu sagen das
ist definitiv kein Armreifen also ich
kann es gerade nicht aufziehen das
musste Timo machen hier finde ich aber
besser von der Größe ich weiß nicht ob
es mir nur so vorkommt aber das ist
nicht ganz so groß wie das andere und
ich finde das sehr hübsch das passt
natürlich perfekt zu der Kette toll ich
mach mal 50 € 19 ich glaube es ist
wieder
Schmuck noch ein Ring ich flipp
doch also na ja so rockig K wenn man
sich so drüber lustig macht was Männer
ein für Schmuck schenken das hat so ein
bisschen dieses Design und diesen Weib
finde ich aber es natürlich wieder ein
tolles Design damit das mehrere Menschen
tragen können kann man das einfach so
jetzt ja du kannst i einfach größer
ziehen Bo finde ich obwohl doch das
Design ist schon schön es sah auf dem
ersten Blick so aus aber so angezogen
sieht das schon cool aus also ihr dürft
mir bloß nicht sagen dass mir
Silberschmuck besser steht ne ich habe
nämlich ein gelb goldenen Verlobungsring
bekommen ich weiß das ein Verlobungsring
und darüber dürfte man nicht vergleichen
welche Farbe passt mir besser
Gold oder
Silber ich glaube goldtim können wir den
noch mal umtauschen zwei Pakete für
mir ach ja klar wir haben noch
benefit der por Minimizer ein
verfeinerndes Poren Creme Dings 10 € die
letzten vier
21 na klar komm was haben wir hier von
baror der clay multileanser ein tolles
Reinigungsmittel für die ganze Familie
wahrscheinlich nicht das ist
wahrscheinlich für die ältere Generation
also mich mittlerweile mit einbezogen ne
ich will hier niemanden als alt
bezeichnen
8,20 2 ihr wisst was kommt oder ihr
wisst was
kommt okay also ich muss auch sagen ich
liebe diese Schachtel die sind total
cute ich glaube nur Moment darüber reden
gleich yes kleine Ohrringe nee die
fühlen sich billiger an als die vom
letzten Jahr ich glaube ich reagiere
allergisch drauf Drama Baby das ist hier
Drama meinem Ohr bin bisschen durch der
Tag war heute lang Leute der Tag war
lang 23 im vorletzten Türchen befind ich
Flip doch
aus ach wisst ihr was die verlose ich
auch an euch guck doch mal das sieht aus
guck mal wie das glänzt denkt mir noch
das ist ein echter Diamant nee denk man
nicht schön hör mal die ist doch toll
5790 wird gleich mal hier eingetragen
meine Ohren klimbern hört ihr das
wartet
24 es ist Weihnachten wir gehen zu
unserem Adventskalender und wir glitzern
so schön wie wie der Weihnachtsbaum und
wir
haben
baror ja gut ich meine es gab die ganze
Zeit Schmuck warum sollte ein
weihnachtenschmuck drin sein ich hätte
es anders rum gemacht glaube ich ich
hätte die Kette in die 24 gepackt die
mit diesem großen Stein und das hätte
ich vielleicht ein Tag vorher die drei
pflegepack
Ampullen Hydra plus Multivitamin und
Lift
Express das kostet doch wieder viel
14,99 interesting Ch
80% der Türchen waren teurer als das es
kommt natürlich auch nicht immer auf den
Preis an hört auf das zu denken wie viel
Schmuckteile hatten wir z okay also 12
Schmuckteile sind drin und 12 Produkte
von barbor Rituals und benefit Bar macht
irgendwie total Sinn für diese Marke
weil das irgendwie so dieses ja keine
Ahnung es passt irgendwie für mich
gedanklich zusammen Rituals ja auch ist
okay finde ich ein bisschen weird da
drin in der Kombination weil benefit ist
für mich eher so eine jüngeres Publikum
und dann hatte man von Benefit auch
eigentlich nur zwei Größen also zwei so
probedinger weiß nicht ob das sein muss
aber mir kam gerade der Gedanke guck mal
wie klein diese Türchen sind guck mal
wie klein dieses Schächtelchen ist klar
man möchte vielleicht nicht nee warum
also ich finde Ansage an Paul Valentine
ne Kalender sage ich gleich aber das war
schon letztes Jahr
so so und schon ist er zusammen geklappt
wer produziert euren adventskal also wer
das ist so leicht das ist so locker und
das Ding ist sofort auseinander gefallen
und wenn man es auch hinstellt da ist
nichts so stabiles da also der erste
Look ist schön und dann rcht alles
auseinander und wackelt und sitzt
einfach nicht gut und dann die Größe
kann der Kalender nicht viel kleiner
sein also weil die paar Produkte die
Platz brauchen ja gut dann kriegt das
halt eine größere Schachtel aber da
waren ja teilweise in so großen
Schachteln dann so so kleine Dinger drin
denkt euch da noch mal was aus sitzt da
noch mal auf dieser Idee dass ihr
vielleicht einfach die Dinger kleiner
macht doch süß wenn es ein kleiner
Adventskalender ist weil ganz ehrlich
dieses wacklige zerbrechlige Stück hier
also ja geht besser geht besser mein
Fazit zum Schmuck ich weiß nicht warum
vielleicht liegt's daran dass der
goldene Schmuck mit 14 Karat vergoldet
ist der silberne Schmuck wirkt um
einiges billiger ist einfach so ja ich
bin ja es wirkt billiger fertig trotzdem
finde ich die Auswahl wieder vom Schmuck
sehr schön ich würde aberid also he
leider ich würde die Preise nur nicht
bezahlen also die Ketten also die kostet
ja z.B so teilweise 60 € nicht zahlen
bei Brot oder sonst wo für
Edelstahlketten kann ich ja auch also
weniger zahlen die Qualität ist aber
bchen besser als bei vielen anderen
Anbietern und ja man zahlt 170 € und
jetzt rechnen wir mal zusammen was ich
zusammeschrieben habe und dann sehen wir
mal ob wir die 811 versprochenen Euros
kriegen Skandal betrug Paul Valentine
macht d ade ich habe nur 615 €
rausbekommen so was wollt ihr von mir
hören dieser Kalender lohnt sich auf
jeden Fall und jetzt stellt euch mal vor
ihr seid noch barbor Fan und Rituals Fan
dann bekommt ihr wirklich für 170 € ein
Haufen an Produkten ich weiß nicht ob
meine Meinung ein bisschen
voreingenommen ist aber dadurch dass ich
überhaupt kein Silberschmuck besitze
habe ich mich gerade wirklich über jedes
Teil gefreut weil ich einfach ja nichts
habe das einzige was gefallen hat ist
dieses Armband finde halt diesen Look in
diesen Ketten ist ist irgendwie nicht so
ganz meins und wenn ihr drauf gewartet
habt euch jetzt Paul Valentine und hol
endlich habe ich Silberschmuck schreibt
mir sehr gerne in die Kommentare was ihr
zu dem Kalender sagt und wir sehen uns
dann in zwei Tagen wieder ne Leute das
geht jetzt hier noch so weiter wir
ziehen durch es werden Kalender geöffnet
bis zum Umfallen